Welcome to our project
Google Developers Hackademy,
where Latin American
Spanish-speaking experts
will show you some of our tools,
developer products,
APIs and new tricks.
I'm glad to introduce,
in Google Developers Hackademy,
the Android SDK
introduction course,
created and given
by Enrique Diaz,
from GDG Androidtitlan in Mexico.
This course is divided
into four parts.
We invite you to watch it
and learn along. Let's start.
Hi. Welcome to the Android SDK
introduction course.
My name is Enrique Diaz,
one of the co-organizers
of GDG Androidtitlan.
Besides, I've been developing
Android apps professionally
since 2009.
By the end of this course,
you'll be able
to develop apps
with fundamental concepts
such as Views, Layouts,
Fragments, Intents
and Activities.
The goal of this first lesson
is to go through
3 important points.
We will learn about
the history of Android,
we'll check current statistics
and why it is important
to start developing
for the platform,
and finally, we will analyze
what's coming in the future
for Android.
But first, I'd like you
to ask yourself these questions:
What's the difference between
a Fragment and an Activity?
Two:
What's Android Manifest?
Three:
What's an Intent?
If you're able to answer
these questions,
then you need to wait
for the advanced course.
Brief history of Android.
In 2003, Andy Rubin,
along with 3 other people,
created a company called
"Android Inc."
Back then,
their goal was to develop
an operative system
for digital cameras.
In 2005 it was acquired
by Google
and there were
no further news until 2007,
when Google,
along with other companies
devoted to develop
telecommunications chipsets
as well as hardware developers,
created a thing called
Open Handset Alliance.
OHA launched Android OS
as an alternative
to innovate on the side
of the final consumer
of mobile phones.
In October 2008,
the first all-Android mobile
was launched,
version 1.0,
and from there it started
growing immensely.
In 2009 they had a 2.9%
market share,
and currently, in 2013,
we own a global 82%.
Nowadays, Android
has nearly 1.5 million
daily activations.
Besides, there are nearly
900 million devices
since the platform was launched.
And the download history
reaches 48 billion apps
downloaded since 2008.
Finally, there are 17 billion
push notifications every day
for the users of this platform.
But why should I care
about all this?
Simple.
If you're an Android developer,
you'll be able to reach
and sell to all these people
that are using
the platform today.
The future of computing:
Android.
Remember we talked
about OHA?
They launched a totally
Open Source operative system.
That means any developer
of consumer electronic devices
can make use
of the operative system.
Televisions, cameras,
automobiles, even watches,
are capable of having Android
as their operative system,
so this represents
a huge chance for all of us.
Picture this scenario:
Currently, keys to enter
your house or your car,
if you lose them,
they're no longer useful, ever,
because you can't enter anymore
and you have to replace them
with something physical again,
something that hasn't been
reutilized or improved
in hundreds of years.
What if you built a bolt
that recognizes a relative
trying to enter,
who has an Android device,
and it opened automatically?
Now, my question to you is:
What scenarios and devices
can you imagine
that can be replaced
by Android nowadays?
RECAPITULATION
Let's recapitulate.
In this lesson we learned
three vary valuable things:
First, we identified
the history of Android.
We learned where it comes from
and what's going on today.
We knew its present,
how many activations
there are nowadays,
and why it is important
to develop Android apps.
And besides,
we looked into the future,
which seems to be
very promising.
Next time we will discover
the main tools to develop
applications for Android
using an IDE, such as Eclipse.
My name is Enrique Diaz and,
keep on programming!